[Music]
four years ago I was basically
unemployed I Wanderer with no home
but now I'm a husband and a father
and I wouldn't have it any other way
and I did it pops
my job was a little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
billion people
and Peep every known
to call this place home
but that doesn't mean they don't like me
I'm gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds dear
I'm gonna murder his family
and burn his kingdom to ask
he must be stopped for a global meltdown
is imminent
I think I know someone might be able to
help us
fool you look rough
good job brother high five do not call
me brother
but I cannot believe you let this happen
you know well I hate this job true king
built Bridges right
two King Building Bridges
we need to find Manta he's different now
he's stronger than before
it's the black Trident
it's doing King atlan's time there were
Seven Kingdoms
it was a curse upon them all
the time has got magic is spreading
he means to end the bloodline
[Music]
I don't know what I said but we can't
leave our children in the world without
hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
if you lead Seven Kingdoms will follow
[Music]
thank you